my birthday is december 23rd yeah
oh [ __ ] your b-day yeah right before
christmas before christmas
wow what a shitty birthday i know i
don't know that's the wild is your queen
gonna take you out
well she wants to but she was like yo
what what do you do i was like every
year i don't celebrate my birthday yeah
yeah it's gotta be i hate birthdays i
know yeah oh nothing worse
but uh they're cool when you have kids
like you make their birthdays off cool
yeah yeah my parents never did that but
um
for you are you actually a queen for
anything
nah i literally i literally had to
listen her birthday was last week we
celebrated
oh would you get her bro i got us
something last night so she was having a
horrible time her friends came out from
since uh ohio and she like paid for
everyone's bill
like she paid for the for her birthday
yeah her birthday bro huh her friends
were broke
no no they was like then mommy crap like
oh she paid for justin too yeah we told
the story yeah
justin you told troy on what uh that's
your house
oh i missed it oh bro let me tell you
something i probably missed it because
my halloween suit caught on fire
it was before that oh word tell me what
happened yo so last week it was her
birthday and all she went down how did
she turn first of all she turned 30.
i thought i'm dating a little older you
know i like him a little older you know
yeah
so she turns 30 and all her friends fly
out so everybody's 30
30 30. so it's the one time you turn 30.
you know you make it special
so i try to i like yo justin come invite
he was all right cool where were we
going we went to this fancy restaurant
in santa monica what was it called my
mock it started marin
let's start with the m i don't know
mexican moroccan no oh sorry i'm mexican
monday i don't know but either way we
get there all right okay
nice spot they had a mariachi band
playing through the glass that's how
nice it is
now i know i want to i want the real
thing now i didn't know how much drinks
cost
i was like all right cool we just gonna
put it on one bill the bill was 700
something dollars how many people was it
it was like at least like let me see
justin yeah
there's yeah people nine people yeah
dude yeah that makes sense okay nine
people
i don't drink you know alcohol alcohol
appetizers appetizers
everything here the dessert the cake was
there a big [ __ ] there
you know justin was there so okay all
right so look
uh every bit of 900 dollars keep going
so the bill comes yeah so my girl she
already like puts the card out
right i was like yo look little black
thing and uh i was like what are you
doing she was like listen
don't worry about it let's just pay for
it now like i'm over it i'm like yo
everyone's like we're gonna even more
request you tomorrow just give it out
ain't just a bunch of [ __ ]
this one justin that was like no we're
gonna do it now this one justin said no
the lady said let's be more hurt
that's the most justin move ever
she had to pay for her b-day meal now we
go to another spot
right for drinks for drinks this is how
dirty justin is
so we're at drinks right we're all
everyone is at the table
and we're drinking in santa monica now
we go to uh knotty pit on sunset so we
drive all the way back from santa monica
to sunset
all right well if she didn't want to end
over by there yeah we live over there
about there so
that's my queen anyway so we we at the
table right the bill comes again now
this guy our homie pays for it
but this girl leaves early she leaves
ten dollars on the table
nobody sees this knowing damn well sh
her drink was taken
exactly she could have kept that so look
justin
had a honey in his pocket the whole time
he kept trying to pull it out
but he kept putting it back in right he
was like y'all don't need me okay good
you kept putting it back in oh yeah
this is how dirty it is so once he saw
that uh homie paid for the drinks and
the
tip that ten dollars he took it in his
he took that two dollars put it in his
pocket
now the guy sees him the whole time he
sees him the whole time
he thinks i think my homie is having a
conversation jesse just sit there he's
like yo
he looks at me he's like i'm about to
get out of here i was like
he left with the ten dollars so he he
had the most dreams he didn't pay
anything nothing yes matter of fact he
made money
he came up with ten dollars damn so last
night i just threw her a surprise
birthday it was me
jessie and her closest justin again and
justin in favor i don't know how we keep
inviting justin you were a surprise
birthday party where uh at uh this place
called
spartina on melrose oh cool hey did you
get an invite no
i didn't either very [ __ ] strange
well i lost a lot of money yesterday and
i i knew if y'all came
yeah i wasn't going to pay so i had to
come out of my house i asked you to pay
that is
your goddamn right i should have invited
you it hadn't been a free me but but
this is
but it's her birthday it was her
birthday and i wanted to like i also
don't know her so
yeah exactly so i was like yo but she
would listen to the show she loves you
holla
yes martinez on melrose yeah yeah you
said beautiful and nice
and here's the thing they let us book a
8 30 spot they closed at 9.
what kind of [ __ ] that'll kick you
out nah she was so dope she let her stay
till 12.
really yeah oh that was that's a great
time well we was having so
much i'm sorry i'm so what did you get
your girl for her birthday besides
throwing a
free birthday party well what do you do
with a queen who's making over
you know certain figures like you gotta
you gotta you gotta get creative you
gotta get centered around you gotta make
a pottery you gotta make a painting
well i gave it a [ __ ] i i say oh yeah
indoor she already i already gave her
the indoor pictures right already gave
her flowers in a cart like what do you
get a girl who like literally can buy
herself whatever she wants
you know what that's another man the
best thing you can give her
the best thing you can give her that big
dick oh yeah you know i put it down
you know i gave it you know i gave her
that yeah thank you bro hell yeah
let me just tell you something oh did
you pop some john jones uh gas station
no i pop a pill bro i've worked i work
i'll work fine you know and plus i get
up when i know she her break account is
that big
come on come on man that's all that
motivation i need yeah she didn't get
her anything that's cool
well yeah he got her long story short
you got her nothing yeah nobody just
said long story short she paid 900
for her birthday well yeah but she needs
new friends
he's hoes that is true flew from
cincinnati
and here's the thing we went to uh eplp
on sunday
and they took all those pictures and
stuff like that and the bill came
and she still alligator arms alligator
yep yeah
i hate the fake reach i hate the like oh
do you want me to get it on
i'm like damn what the hell yeah or or
what after
someone puts a card down like oh i
didn't why didn't you say something i
would have paid
like yeah well you can still pay yeah it
was like now you got it you got it yeah
i hate i'm like were they decent looking
yeah they were they were like she has
some bad friends but they're not
as her established sure yeah so of
course they look good and then they
bought her boy the one girl bought her
boyfriend
they had a free ride because they stayed
in our spot [ __ ] when i say out
of her place
and i was like yo they we really tried
to give them the bed she was like no
just give them the couch and they had
she bought them a hotel she paid for a
hotel
at uh yeah that's depressing what was
that what's that spot over there in
hollywood
that uh roosevelt the roosevelt she was
over hollywood boulevard yeah
yeah yeah and she just threw up so i was
like you know what you do a lot you
spend a lot of money on your birthday
let me just get you something let me
show you another birthday party you're
gonna pay for it no
i'll pay for it i pay for it yeah but
you paid me with her card yeah i didn't
why didn't no i used my card
i wanted to use her card but i mean cuz
hers is black mine is
rainbow how about that when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son